piloter une formule 1 où une voiture de
rallye c'est l'expérience proposée par
l'espace de simulation highway cette
société lyonnaise s'installe dans le
centre skywest avec la possibilité de se
lancer dans une course avec six joueurs
on va pendant une quarantaine de minutes
commencez par vous équipez vous briefé
vous installer dans les voitures tout
l'intérêt c'est de faire vivre les
sensations que ressentent les pilotes
professionnels
cette activité innovante dans le secteur
du loisir s'accompagne d'une expérience
de réalité virtuelle collaborative avec
plusieurs histoires on a une mission qui
s'appelle iss reste qu on vous envoie
dans l'espace pour une mission de
routine
sauf que ça pas tout à fait se passer
comme ça aurait dû se passer vous allez
avoir 45 minutes vous allez être à 408
km au-dessus de la terre et vous allez
être en équipe pour essayer de
solutionner ce qui se passe on a eu
notre expansion telle opération black
space on n'est plus dans la peau d'un
commando ayew et propose aussi des
scénarios des skates game classique une
entreprise déjà expérimentée elle a
ouvert son premier centre en 2008 à lyon
avec des prix variant de 25 à 99 euros
en fonction des activités notre modèle
économique il est véritablement bâti sur
une clientèle grand public et quand l
entreprise aujourd'hui saint quentin en
yvelines c'est calme le deuxième pôle
économique de l'ouest parisien
donc sur cette partie entreprises
c'était une véritable valeur ajoutée
derrière ça reste un bassin population
qui est dense ce nouveau centre cible
aussi la clientèle parisienne objective
des faits un chiffre d'affaires
prévisionnel de 2 5 millions d'euros
l'ouverture est prévue le 7 février
prochain